the European Championships his
football's biggest party outside the
World Cup but you Eifert like sporting
bodies worldwide has pressed pools and
celebrations like this Wembley was
supposed to be the centerpiece hosting
the semi finals and final of the
tournament held across the continent for
the very first time but now Euro 2020
has become Euro 2021 and the National
Stadium is abandoned staff including the
boss have been sent home for their own
safety now contemplating how football
can survive unprecedented upheaval
we're very you April made today there
are more important things than football
going on right now and it was the right
decision to be made we look forward to
welcoming the euros here in 15 months
and they're sure that at that time we
can put on a brilliance on them ticket
holders have been assured they will be
refunded if they can't attend matches
next year and with football leagues
across Europe in limbo it offers some
help that the domestic season's well
underway already could yet be completed
Liverpool are on the brink of a
longed-for Premier League title and want
to play on once it's safe to do so all
the clubs they want the season null and
voided what is certain is that legal
battles will rage long after were over
the worst of the coronavirus if the
seasons cancelled there are a number of
big issues the broadcaster's may
complain that they haven't had the value
of what they've paid for how are you
going to determine whether there's
promotion or relegation and are you
going to have the playoffs all of these
are very big questions for football
that's why most people would much prefer
it if it's possible to continue the
season but if not this may be fought out
amongst lawyers rather than football
players another team will assess the
financial implications of delaying Euro
2020 for both UEFA and for the national
federations but it's all relative small
fry compared to what a postponement or a
cancellation of the Olympic Games would
mean the International Olympic Committee
are refusing to contemplate changes to
total in 2020
cost 11 billion pounds two-stage Team GB
representatives are in Japan at the
moment scoping out training facilities
for British athletes really traveling
backwards and forwards there for five
years and we're just putting the final
touches in place for the team so just
really fine-tuning what we think is a
fabulous footprint for our athletes to
compete here in the summer
Japan's Olympic Minister insisted it
will go ahead as planned on July the
24th striking a hopeful chord among
athletes how this optimism will age is a
different question Martha Kellner Sky
News